today we will talk a bit more about the
kind of foundations of graduation in
terms of
kind of a more simplistic or theoretical
way of thinking of validation and how to
use that to design your next validation
so this is not the teacher how to use
spreadsheets to create a bar chart but
to say what makes a good pie chart
the point I want to make here is there's
no kind of
universally accepted the framework or
Siri about what is a good validation so
to some extent it's almost like art
there's still lots of like say personal
interpretation depends on particular
data or user cases just says that I I
assume there's no Universal way of
writing a good novel people would have
their own implementations even they've
been centuries people trying to do that
computer science are not designed then
very good question so actually
um so take the validation just because
it's nature is kind of across a few
different fields so obviously even
within the computer size it was related
to computer Graphics which is a more on
the visual side but also the human
computer interaction in terms of how
people use it and in my work actually I
see quite a few colleagues from the
psychology or even Neuroscience
departments or the understanding the
more fundamental thing for example in
the human brain part how the sea react
to different visuals so it's kind of
very cross-disciplinary so today I
really just only want to cover Graphics
which are these things the video things
you see on the screen and it's composed
of two parts and one is called the marks
and the other one called channels these
might be called different names in
different context of discussions and the
concept here is probably the more
important part
and so first and Marx is what I would
call data items so let's assume you have
a spreadsheet which lists all the
products in the supermarket or shop so
each row is a product which is an items
so these can be represented visually as
a mark and so you can imagine you can
potentially use a point to represent one
product depends on what the validation
is maybe a line in your bar chart a bar
or you can have more funds repetition
for each product and as a shape or even
3D shape you can have different
dimensionality without the mark but this
really represents one data items or one
entity so that's marks
and then the other one called the
channels which is the visual
representation of the attributes of your
item so you could say you can think
about the Paradox it has to say the name
the weight and it will be associated
with information like the sales the
profits these kind of I call attributes
of the items and usually if it will be
the columns in your spreadsheet and
these are the things you probably want
to also include in your audition as well
so you want to show the product and then
other information social with the
product like the names the price the
profit and so on so forth
um so a large part of the validation is
just say mapping the attributes to the
visual so I say I want to show the price
then I can choose to use say the color
or maybe the size to show the color then
there's a choice there and often there
are more than one attributes you want to
show and then you have a choice between
which one to use which channel just
taking a very simple example to explain
this
so if this is like a scat plot and we
have some showing the some kind of
product information and we're showing
the profits of each product the sales
product and then the type of product so
it's showing three attributes in the
data we are using a 2d graph because and
the color itself is not the spatial
Dimension but also that's usually
actually a good thing because if you're
not limited to spatial Dimension that
means you can be on 3DS so you can go
say five six seven ten and so on and so
forth okay and then back to the marks
and channels what are the marks here
okay the marks are the uh the type the
colors basically is that right uh I
think that's the channel uh oh sorry
yeah so Marx is the one the dots exactly
exactly so the marks represents each
items in English will be each product
which will be the dot and then the
channels we already said colors color
and also the place on the graph yeah
exactly so I mean more formally we call
these positions basically X Y
coordinates or the positions so this
looks a little bit busy but really to
show you it just says okay when I have
some attributes that I want to show for
example the price what will be the best
channel to show do I use position color
or maybe 3D or maybe tilted the levels
yeah so I'm not going to go through that
you've got the list but generally what
people did is did lots of experiments
for example they want to find out
whether use position is better or using
colors better so lots of small
experiments the pairwise comparison the
kind of eventually become this list and
it's not second absolute order for
example these two say either using the
luminance or the grayscale or use the
saturation level of the color they have
kind of similar level of effectiveness
so the third and the top is the more
effective ones in general at the bottom
are the less effective one thing they
are particularly old so very quickly see
the position X Y is actually very
effective and then say for example 3D
shapes is usually not very good so at
least in academics there's a big part of
the visualization research Community
think you probably should try to avoid
3D if you can just because it's not very
good at the replanting and also we have
these two parts so the left part is to
represent numbers basically so these are
type of data you can see Europe and use
serial number say price profit and on
the right hand side is the more
categorical type of values for example
different type of products say they have
they have distinction but they you can't
really do think any operations they're
not usually a member
and again so there's a limited number of
channels usually can be used for
different type depends on type of
attributes the effectiveness is also a
little bit different
okay
uh yeah and so this is
people do experiment try to understand
how accurate a channel is
so each line you have is one channel and
then so this one would be the actual
value the x-axis and the y-axis will be
the perceived value
and so you can see the purple line here
is lens essentially similar to position
so the actual value is very similar to
the user perceived values so which is a
good thing so anything under this for
example brightness that means people
underestimate
so if for example if you make twice as
bright
and then people maybe only think only
increased by 50 percent
whereas on this side about this purple
line are the ones which people
overestimate and so what they
included here is electric shock so if
you're increasing voltage by just a tiny
bit the people feeling is way way more
painful yeah you have a number there
which is 3.5 times more painful but yeah
but I think the more important thing is
just the kind of General saying you over
and estimate and also the important
thing is you try to be in the middle as
much as possible that which give you an
accurate
yes but otherwise you have to you can
actively compensate for this which is
not what we usually do as a human okay
and so this is the last one so we're
going to do a one of these little
experiments we mentioned earlier on just
to see how accurate we add human and do
we actually tend to over underestimate
the visual representations
and so I have three representations here
so we're all representing a number so
the first one I use color
so I use say the darker the color the
bigger the value
and they're going to ask Richard to pick
say do you think this one on the right
is one half times bigger or darker or or
more saturated or or twice or two and a
half times more saturated compared to
the color on the left
um so if you're trying this yourself I
would recommend trying not to sing too
long about it always think about it
because when you usually look at the
audition you would not think about is it
accurate or not or question your
decisions
so just take your kind of instant and
gut reaction and go with it and I will
show the answers after this but if
you're interested and you can put that
in the comments what do you think it
should be I'm going to say
sorry this is darkness is it yeah it's a
darker means more larger value I'd say
twice two okay and we're gonna do all of
these three and then come back to look
at it yeah and then this one is using
lens so I think that's two and a half
times two and a half times okay and this
one is area the last one 1.5 yeah 1.5
okay now I'm looking at it and I'm
changing my mind straight away because
no no don't think so this is the
important thing so the key here is not
to think too much and use
um kind of your first intuition for
reaction because and when you look at
the actual the devil Edition you
probably would not just think about
there really is it's just say you'll
have some impression immediately and
then that's what will be answered most
of the time you're not going to scan
carefully think about the question of
your choice is so the answer is actually
it's always twice oh they're all twice
always twice ah okay and so I mean quite
a few times people actually overestimate
this part as well also thinks maybe it's
more than twice darker than this
obviously they can set the RGB values if
you look at the here before so the
saturation is about here so it's people
tend to overestimate and then areas here
people tend to underestimate
yeah so again so it doesn't work for
everyone I think even I do this in class
right I have like sometimes close to 100
students each person would have slightly
different accuracy for these channels
but but in general I think these are
kind of much larger scales experiment
with hundreds or even more people and it
has been kind of revalidated afterwards
as well so that's usually accurate
all the changes that it's made to the
image it now thinks that that is over 99
likelihood of being a coffee mug can you
see the coffee mug there if it is it's
uh it's definitely by one of the more
abstract the way we solve this is with
something called a Bellman equation so
the Bellman equation describes how good
a particular action choice is